one of the most stunning revelations
from bob woodward's
new book rage is that donald trump's
former secretary of defense jim mattis
went to the director of national
intelligence dan coats and said
dan the time may come where we need
collective action
on donald trump which by every
reasonable interpretation that is code 4
the cabinet may have to come together
and use the 25th amendment to remove
donald trump bob woodward's book also
alleging
that jim mattis saw donald trump as
quote dangerous
and quote unfit and in a separate
conversation
recounted by bob woodward jim mattis
reportedly
said to the dni dan coats quote the
president has no moral compass
to which dan coats replied true to him
a lie is not a lie it's just what he
thinks
he doesn't know the difference between
the truth
and a lie so let's kind of dig into this
at the big picture level i'm guessing
most of my audience understands
it's not normal it's not typical
for multiple high-ranking individuals
like the secretary of defense and the
director of national intelligence
to be talking together about hey we
might at some point need to act
to remove the president because he is
unfit and he cannot lead that is not
typical
that did not happen during barack obama
it didn't happen during george w bush
although certainly george w bush did a
lot of things that were
absolutely atrocious and and and
disgusting
this is not normal now what do they mean
when they say collective action
by every stretch of of my imagination
it can mean one thing and one thing only
which is the potential use of the 25th
amendment to remove a president
now the 25th amendment it's you know
available this is a public document
as you as you know um it has four
articles in it
the first three refer to other
circumstances where a president would
have to be replaced for example
if the president is incapacitated for
for some reason or if a president were
to die
the fourth article of the 25th amendment
is the relevant one here and thinking
about what jim mattis was talking about
and
that fourth article of the 25th
amendment says
that the vice president and cabinet
officials can vote on the removal of a
president if the majority votes for
removal
meaning the vp plus the cabinet a letter
goes to the leader the senate pro temp
and the speaker of the house telling
them we
have voted to remove the president the
president is then able to respond if the
president disagrees with his removal or
her removal in this case his removal
the president can write a letter to the
senate in the house saying i am fit to
serve
and then both houses of congress would
have to vote now
in the meantime if the vice president
sends a letter saying i agree that the
president is unfit
until the house and senate vote the vice
president
becomes acting president of the united
states it's sticky and it's sloppy and
it's convoluted
but the point here is jim mattis the
then
secretary of defense brought this to the
director of national intelligence and
said
we may need to do this we may need
collective action
that alone is one of the biggest
scandals of the last many decades
the fact that this was a conversation
that took place
at the highest levels is completely
outrageous
and out of this world a scandal if the
world made
sense donald trump would have already
resigned based on everything that well
actually
if the world made sense donald trump
never would have been elected given that
he was
if the world made sense the countless
scandals that donald trump has been
involved in
would have led to a resignation long ago
the world does not make sense
and instead we are faced with a very
real prospect not of donald trump's
removal
but of donald trump being awarded
another four years and fascinatingly
that there are trumpists who heard this
news that jim mattis was thinking
we may actually have to remove this guy
and some of those trumpets
reacted by saying i told you the
military was planning a coup
against donald trump now of course
mattis is gone
mattis was talking about this in his
role as a member of the cabinet
happening to be secretary of defense
this was not a military action that was
being considered
it's a cabinet action but the fact that
they will excuse
anything they will find a way to say
donald trump is the victim here
donald billionaire guy born with a spoon
in his mouth
has become in the eyes of many of his
followers and in his own eyes
the biggest victim the most poorly
treated man on earth you would
he would have you believe um it is truly
amazing and again i don't want to get
ahead of myself but
i'm putting together my thoughts i don't
think this is going to have
any impact on donald trump and we'll
deal with that tomorrow
in the meantime what is your reaction to
these audio leaks do you think they will
have any bearing
whatsoever on the upcoming election let
me know on twitter
where you can find me at d pacman
d-p-a-k-m-a-n
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a practical
and affordable way to take control of
your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually
have time to listen to you you get the
personal attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video